here comes the sun
totally
[Applause]
so who knew did eddie know did your kids
know
eddie was the only person who knew the
kids did not know in fact i told them
last night and
my little one he goes dang it i lost a
bet with my mom
i was like sorry bud leanne and husband
of nine years eddie cybrian co-parent
two sons with his ex-wife former beverly
hills housewife brandi glanville
but who knew leanne had such a good
poker face
i'm not on the massacre when i got off
that interview i was like they believe
me
and i can't lie because it's like it
just shows like right here on my face
2021 is going to be a beast for you
because it's 25 years
since the release of blue
we love to march down memory lane at et
and show you
the moment when we first met you oh my
gosh okay
[Music]
i don't want people to think of me as a
13 year old singing sensation kind of
thing
i want them to think of me as an artist
and for my music right now i think i'm
going to stick with country
maybe one day i'll go into pop a little
bit or you know something
it's so funny i love it and you know
talk about taking off that mask
it's like i had to wear a mask it had to
be piano rhymes and at some point
you know i think in my life
unconsciously like really wanted to burn
that down and i look at that and i'm
like wow
i've come a long way but i love that
girl she was a strong young woman
you